hey welcome back for those that are just
tuning in I'm Jesse I'm here at the
Wolfram tech conference 2017 I'm just
talking with developers and people using
our tech and kind of interesting ways
and right now I'm here with Etienne who
will tell us a little bit about what he
does here at the company and some of the
new kind of features he's been working
on yeah I mean so what's your name it's
in Ghana and I've been working and were
from for almost five years now
you domain of machine learning and so
I've been developing functions machine
learning functions for the warm language
and and I'm the manager of the machine
learning team just about a dozen the
people now so we just talked to shadi
and she mentioned that they're
implementing a lot of these new neural
net features for image and audio
processing so can you tell me a little
bit more about the family of net
functions as I kind of just call them
now yeah there are many functions that
were working on so the first one was
image notify which was two years he is
and a half ago I think yeah it's been a
while so yeah it's been a while but
still good I think and and since then we
are kind of working on many more
projects of this kind such as things for
speech to text all things form not just
imagine if I is about finding what's the
main object in an image but we also know
function I find all the objects in
imagine or some sort of object detection
and as often a big part is to is to
gather the data set and an exciting now
because the image processing team is
working more with us so now we have
common meetings and
it's nice that many more people are
using the genuine I took framework to
try these functions so I I read your
recent blog post on the Wolfram blog and
you talked about something called the
fully automated data scientist I don't
know what that is do you wanna I mean
personally that's that's something that
I'm very interested in and it's kind of
the end goal in Stuart Weber system to
which you could just you know throw data
at and just start I mean conversation
with I mean for example in the blog I
think I was using the example of
database to do this automated data
scientist application and ask ok how
many quests are am I going to sell next
Sunday and and the system will gather
will we look at the data historical data
we also take data from outside for
example it might might add I don't know
they tie by the weather that it was each
days because it's figured that it would
be relevant to predict the amount of
sales for given day and then we just
answer in natural language well
according to my data external data and
so on I predict that you will sell
between 60 and 70 parcel so I so the
neural nets are supposed to that's kind
of the fully automated feature because
traditional data science is you know you
have humans interpreting the data and
kind of making inferences about it
so is are the neural nets or sort of the
analog to this human interpretation is
that what you're hoping will eventually
happen with this so it's quite different
I mean so baby me just to clarify what
was working on this on one part there is
high-level functions such as classify or
predict whose goal is to be
so it's not fully automated at ascent is
because it's just about the modeling
parts okay to have ultimately descent
into some other other steps involved but
definitely the goal is to make that
ascends as easy as possible right that
even someone that doesn't know about
machine learning for example can just
have it at a set plug put it into
classify and it will produce under the
neon Network part is a bit more for
experts
so it's bit more for people that know
bit more what they doing I want you to
play around with with the model more
control or more flexibility as well and
although we also try to make this
internet framework as easy to use as
possible and I think honestly it's
probably the easiest framework to use
out there like we had we had some
stories of people that were like if it
wasn't that easy in mathematica I
wouldn't have done one story that I
don't know that I like is his the story
of Daniel George with with PhD students
at the LIGO experiments and he used the
framework to - for example to classify
the different events you know they are
murdering gravitational waves and then
I'm trying to figure out is it you know
- black hole that collides or to a
neutron star that collide like in
happened it has been announced a few
days ago right and and for that they
needed a classifier and used our
framework to train a neural network in
order to to classify the type of events
and and he was saying really if it
wasn't that easy I wouldn't have done it
so we also try to make the only
framework as easy as possible but it's a
bit of a different goal it's a bit cheap
right although we use neural network
inside the fully automated functions and
then the disturb thing that you
mentioned is using our tools with our
data to create functional
imagine densify and so I guess with the
I mean 11.3 is gonna be coming out soon
what are some I know unless we're
introduced in version 11
so what are some big improvements that
are gonna be implemented in 11.3 that
were not in the eleven point two okay so
eleven point three there won't be so
many visible improvement there will be a
few extra layers okay
they will be way too many plates do
network better that's something that I
am quite happy about is that I won't
even network I represented symbolically
like it's an expression right yeah right
which is a you know which people know
well about when they use of language
although in other words it's pretty
different
so why you define a network is really
with a classical program type thing and
then you cannot really manipulate this
network well whereas as you can you know
take a network chop it off add a new
layer very easily replace a layer and
there's a bunch of tools to do kind of
neural network surgery in a way that
will be added to 11.3 this is quite
exciting and another thing that we are
very excited is what will happen after
probably darshan well maybe it's to kind
of generalize our framework to be even
more flexible you know that that's I
think it's a common trend in your
network framework that at first
programming and your network is a bit
programming with a graphical language
like you say oh you have some some
different layers and you're connecting
them this way you know and but this
sometimes have limitation sometimes you
want to write in a more like classic
programming way like first of all with
loops right or if statements and in
domains just natural or producing that's
that's very powerful that's a model that
is very hard to express with just one
fixed graph
and so they've been some summer
framework out there they're doing that
and and right now we are thinking very
hard about the best design to integrate
this type of you know to add this kind
of additional expressivity how to define
networks but in the same time still
keeping it very easy and which i think
is very appealing feature yeah well like
just about I mean like you mentioned
people who use from language will know
this I mean everything including actual
front end like notebook files are
symbolic Wolfram language code so it's
not surprising that these but these
neural networks are also I'm gonna feel
a little that's word you can manipulate
them oh well thanks for talking me at
the end I really appreciate it
and again if you have comments just
leave them down in the comment section
we can't get to it
during these live sessions but someone
will get back to you later also check
out community double from calm someone
probably already had your questions at
some point or maybe they didn't so who
knows you can start a new discussion so
anyway thank you